la generación de la independencia con
esa frase cerró la primera ministra
Nicolás turgeon el congreso del partido
Nacional de Escocia quiere celebrar un
nuevo referendo de autodeterminación el
19 de octubre de 2023
[Aplausos]
la independencia esencial es esencial
para escapar del control y la mala
gestión de Westminster es esencial para
que los gobiernos por los que votamos
protejan adecuadamente nuestro sistema
de salud para construir una nueva
asociación de iguales con las otras
naciones de las Islas es esencial Si
queremos estar de vuelta en la Unión
Europea Show
el tribunal supremo de Reino Unido
comienza el martes a analizar si el
parlamento escocés tiene competencias
para convocar el referendo la decisión
llegará entre 6 y 8 semanas los expertos
creen que la corte no dará el aval para
la consulta de ser así sturgeon ha dicho
que convertirá las próximas elecciones
en un plebiscito el gobierno conservador
de Reino Unido se niega a celebrar el
referéndum así lo ha justificado la
primera ministra listras tengo muy claro
que en 2014 cuando hubo un referendo
dijimos que es una vez por generación
Pues a la derrota del independentismo
por el 55% contra el 45% en la consulta
de 2014 los escoceses recurren a la
votación a favor del brexit de 2016 Para
reivindicar volver a tener el derecho a
decidir sobre su autodeterminación